[Musik]
wir sind hier auf mallorca lasst uns
hierher geführt hat wie so wie hier
sitzen und was wir hier erlebt haben
werdet ihr gleich aufwand wir sitzen vor
feinsten mallorquinischen tapas wir
haben cramon ibérico wir haben typisch
mallorquinische kroketten wie nicht
harvey letzten zwei tage waren crazy
alles angefangen mit einem langen flug
hafenaufenthalt in köln rund
50 euro an
[Musik]
ich würde sagen unsere zeit für so ein
interessent
und durch den laden in dem von ein
bisschen wunderschön ganz zufällig
ich finde willst du die wahrnehmung von
mallorca ist wirklich so einseitig man
kann die super hessen so viel ein leben
so eine schöne insel und wir haben das
wirklich wirklich zu verstehen gelernt
wir sind dann auf jeden fall mitten in
der nacht angegriffen und am nächsten
morgen ging es dann los und dann haben
wir auch schon leiten bekannten
getroffen der nelson müller allerdings
auch dabei betont
tage verbracht haben gefrühstückt und
sind dann erstmal angefangen was man
halt so
[Musik]
heute ist fühlt sich so verkehrt an aber
so richtig jetzt hier auf zypern amaral
zu sein weil wir gestern
angekommen sind heute früh raus und
jetzt machen wir so eine katamaran
partei gefeiert
[Musik]
diese katamaran frage noch nie da
ist jetzt wieder sein mit der ganzen
truppe da wurde noch gegrillt die farben
vom meer das ist noch einiges passiert
ich finds kann auch gutes in diesem
killing in dem gesamten restaurant
sitzen weil das ist ein bisschen so der
rat von der ganzen reise zu es war sehr
sehr entspannt dadurch dass das ist so
schön cremig so eine leichte säure dabei
den wir uns kurz frisch gemacht haben
sind wir damit ab in den bus zu den
salinen gefahren wie gesagt wurden
eingeladen von claudia renk und haben
dort zuallererst an den salinen
betroffen also eine zelle getroffen das
ist die person die meersalz ernte ich
bin irgendwie lustig dass man als erntet
und wir haben erst mal verstanden ihr
komplettes produkt seitz wird dieses
lehrer ist natürlich nicht so gerne
benutzten der kirchenrat in der guten
küche natürlich viel wie das ganze
funktioniert klattens dort wird erst mal
mehr wasser abgepumpt in verschiedenen
stufen quasi dann dauert also im großen
feld zum kleineren feld sondern noch
klein und hält bis zu diesen kleinen
rechtecken und am ende ist dann die
salzkonzentration so hoch in dem wasser
dass es sich oben absetzung sich kleine
kristalle fortsetzt ist das flotte style
also die blume des seins ist alles
andere ist nicht dieses premium produkt
in solchen decken hier wird das meersalz
produziert nämlich koch das ist einfach
mehr was es schon weiter und immer so
das ist einer der orte von dem einst der
lebensmittel kommt dass man so täglich
konsumiert und man versteht es jetzt das
ding ist also gleich wieder eingeladen
ich würde auch gar nicht dass es ist
wichtig aber es war so interessant zu
sehen und dieses produkt welches man so
häufig schon benutzt hat in der küche
und es entsteht warum das so eine hohe
güter hat man uns besonders dass ich und
einfach so ein bisschen mehr so zu
verstehen wie das alles zusammenkommt so
viele selbst auch salz
ich habe mein eigenes jetzt gerade im
koffer und freue mich dass jetzt auch
meine eigenen küche einzusetzen
denn zweimal
im anschluss damit ist blutig trocknet
noch so dünnen netzen ausgebreitet dann
sind wir weiter spaziert vom rest der
salinen angeschaut die großen becker
davon dass wir wiederkommen sind war
schon trocken jetzt kann ich zu hause
ist
wir haben keinen produktionsschritt
ausgelassen und dieses abgefüllt habe
ich jetzt gerade in meinem koffer in
einer kleinen bakken drin und ich freue
mich sehr darauf dass meine eigenen
küche einsetzen können um jedem zu sagen
das ist mein sollte ich das gerne das
ist schon sehr cool also zu verstehen
wie das überhaupt zusammen kommt das
sieht ja wunderschön aus die fahne ist
glühend heiß ist es hat sie gerade
gesagt das gleiche die bayern also in
der charta nicht aber sie sieht so schön
aus das ist wirklich nicht
das essen gestern haben auch wir
verbrauchen also dieses ganze setting da
diese lange tafel da mit den vielen
verschiedenen gästen wirklich
professionelle fußballspielerin wfp
nationalteam werden modedesigner kirchen
dem sternekoch jemand das war nicht
nicht so trotzdem versucht schon sehr
sehr schönes event und ich habe mich
sehr über die einladung gefreut und
dachte mir ich mache das auch weil es
glaube ich auch eine schöne sache ist
immer so teilen kann ich aber lasst uns
jetzt noch nie hier gesehen schon kann
man hier einmal reinkommen das ist
möglich nur auf dem boden das ist um
diese kleinen trauben hier haben eine
unverblümte sachfragen der preis ist das
risotto reis auf jeden fall ist richtig
cremig unfassbare mallorca so kassandra
ich muss wirklich noch mal her kommt
noch ein bisschen mehr zeit alles
erkunden will alles was wir gegessen
haben bei dem event gestern das jetzt
hier sogar die kleinen delikatessen die
wir im hotel beim frühstück ab
also ich hätte es nicht gedacht dass
mallorca so gut zum essen
[Musik]
mach erst mal wenn das jetzt vielleicht
auf dem tisch stehen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
leute also wirklich wir waren schon so
ein bisschen ab reisestress und so
dieser laden hat einfach mal komplett
raus geholt ich war sehr sehr relaxed
ich glaube jetzt an der moderation auch
gemerkt das ist eine echte empfehlung
also ein bisschen teurer auch aber es
lohnt sich auf jeden fall noch ein
großes dankeschön ein vorteil ist dass
wir uns eingeladen haben dass sie das
ermöglicht haben mallorca sehr gutes
glas darum gut zu essen und auch einfach
eine sehr schöne insel nachdem er
gegessen hatten in unserer schönen tafel
hat die band dann noch mal richtig gas
gegeben und nicht nur die band sondern
auch nelson müller kann sich das
mikrofon geschnappt und ich sag mal so
viel wer ist hübschen multitalent
fernsehkoch sternekoch und singen kann
er und auch freestyle deshalb heute ich
das einfach an ich bin dann auch einfach
raus weil der kanal ist unfair
[Musik]
[Applaus]